last week Calista did a wonderful job of
opening the door to what one commentator
has called Jesus's manifesto this text
his opening statement about who he is
and what he's doing being the Jesus we
know his manifesto of course is never
direct its focus is always different and
always strange but we've heard it so
often we may not even think about it
what's the subject of the Sermon on the
Mount what does this what is our passage
today say is it about God is it about
Jesus how does our gospel today begin
it's about you Jesus doesn't start
talking about what's going on up in
heaven he doesn't start talking about
philosophy doesn't they're talking about
psychology even he doesn't start talking
about theology starts talking about you
and who you really are that's a subject
in the Sermon on the Mount it's his
listeners that he's talking about and he
has a message for them about who they
are just a very interesting turn of
topic it's not the way you would think
to start a religion but Jesus is very
interested in his hearers and what they
believe about who they are last week we
heard the Beatitudes all the Blessed B's
that Jesus went through and I like to
hear those not as a command as Callista
said it's not a command it's not go out
and be like this but rather it is saying
these people you you people who are
suffering you people who are excluded
our blubber are really blessed but
that's also a corrective to a particular
belief in the culture by saying this
he's unsanctioned addicting which is a
society and a religious order that say
cursed are you pour for you are excluded
from the kingdom
God Jesus's message is one of welcoming
in all the people who felt that they
were left out on down the line the meek
those were mourning those who hunger for
changed the merciful the pure in heart
the peacemakers Jesus as Jesus blesses
each one he contradicts what his
listeners believe about themselves that
they were cursed and excluded because
they were sinners because there were
Gentiles tax collector shepherds blind
sick too poor to make the necessary
sacrifices or breaking one of so many
laws he looked out at that crowd on the
mountain and saw people all of whom felt
excluded from the kingdom of God the
problem is not whose say even who's
saying this the problem is that Jesus's
listeners believed it they saw
themselves as excluded as beyond the
grace of God as beyond glatt God's
kingdom of justice and peace and today
Jesus goes on from there and start
shut-ins and says you are the salt of
the earth you are the light of the world
you have to understand just how unlikely
that was for these people Lisa this is
not the salt of the earth this is not in
the light of the world as anyone in his
society would have seen it this is the
rabble these are the left out people
these are the people nobody took
seriously and he says you are the salt
of the earth I don't know about you but
whenever I heard that phrase about
someone growing up it seemed to always
be at funerals seem to be sort of an
appreciation for someone after they were
gone that they were you know sort of
humble hard-working good person though
the south of the earth and I want to
rethink that because I think Jesus is
saying something perhaps more literal
that those who were sure that God and
religion had rejected them are now being
invited to enter boldly into the world
around them to spice it up and that's my
thesis for the day that's Christians job
is to spice up the world that may sound
a little too titillating for church I
know so those we can't handle that does
cover your ears but what if Jesus's
challenge as Callista said last week was
to to the people to recognize that they
had been blessed by God to be a blessing
for the whole world and what if we
believe that about ourselves what if his
listeners on the mountain were actually
being told that they had a role in
changing the world by spicing it up with
the truth about who God is and what God
wants and I've been looking for a story
to illustrate this and i read in father
John Shay's commentary is one of my
favorite writers the story of a priest
who he thought of when he heard about
being the salt of the world the spice
that Jesus wanted his followers to be
and he tells the story of this Catholic
Church and he wanted to put up a
basketball hoop in their parking lot so
the teenagers could play basketball and
the pastor suggested that they not only
put up the hoop in the net but they also
by three basketballs and put him in a
net and tie them to the base of the hoop
so that anyone who wanted to play
basketball can come and take a
basketball off the hoop and play and put
it back when they're done now the parish
council was skeptical the basketballs
would be stolen in a minute if they left
them out like this but the pastor said
he had a solution he said he wasn't
going to buy cheap basketballs that
people felt like they could just steal
he was going to buy the very best
basketballs and when people saw that the
church was letting anyone who wanted
play with these very expensive
basketballs they would of course respect
them and not take them the parish
council thought he was crazy
but the pastor has the authority in the
Catholic Church and so he bought his
basketballs and put them in the net at
the base of the hoop and within a week
the first was stolen second one was gone
in about a month and the third lasted
about six months in the parrot but the
parish council was surprised that they
lasted so long but they were also
exultant that the pastor had been wrong
so what did the pastor do he went out
and bought three more basketballs and he
stated the moral of the story as he
understood it in very simple terms good
basketballs for good people that's the
kind of spice I think Christians might
bring to the world that different way of
looking at things that possibility that
when we look out the world we might not
see danger and fear and embarrassment
and failure but that as Christians we
might go out and see good people who
need basketballs I wonder what Jesus
meant when he called his followers to be
salt of the earth was this kind of
spiciness to go against the received
wisdom the established rules for how
things work to believe first of all that
you are good not the you in the broad
sense the universal sense that we
usually think when we come to church you
know big you you as in those people out
there just the way we often think in
church but you as in you you are the
salt of the earth you are good enough
you are loved by God and for that reason
we can convince the world that all are
good
that's the transition the Jesus is
making you are the salt of the earth and
I want you to go out and convince the
rest of the world that they are loved by
God that they are salt as well I think
Christians may be called to be a little
strange these days the temptation i
think in trying to find our place in the
culture is do we want to be what we once
were in charge or do we want to be
apologetic oh we screwed up over the
last twenty centuries and we're very
sorry i'm not sure those are the choices
i think we can instead be the spice in
the world we can be a little different a
little touched a little driven by
jesus's vision which doesn't fit with
any vision that you're going to learn at
yale doesn't fit with any economic
vision political vision psychology
sociology whatever you like it doesn't
fit with any of those it sits above them
all and judges them all it's a different
vision that's brought in to undermine to
flip not in a powerful sense but in the
sense of the good humor and the
confusion that Jesus sewed wherever he
went in order to keep people on their
toes and able to see what's in front of
them the people in front of them I
wonder sometimes if we forget that the
Christian faith is not a stone fortress
built brick by brick brick of
established truths but is God's
irreverent retelling of God's own story
to all of us full of jokes and parables
and twisted logic all seemingly designed
to get people to realize that against
everything they had been told that God
does indeed love people all people one
of my favorite Christian popular books
is by an English of angelical called The
Lost message of Jesus whose name is
Steven chalk and he writes in a very
popular easygoing style about how the
message of Jesus has been
he thinks lost through the centuries
mostly because Christians do a very poor
job of embodying that message and he
suggests through his book this task of
boiling the gospel down to one sentence
of course it fails but it's an
interesting experiment and he gives a
couple of chapters to it and he comes to
one sentence finally and he doesn't say
this is it forever but he says this is
what's right for him he says the message
is that Jesus gives is that the kingdom
of God the in breaking peace of God is
available now to everyone through me
think about that it's available to
everyone everyone now through Jesus
Christ kingdom of God is available now
to everyone
if we believed it how might we act a
couple of weeks ago I shared my idea
that our church might be a place where
faith and adventure meet i said that i
love that world adventure just because
it was so unsure chi but it sounds like
six flags what would it look like if we
went out from this place today truly
believing that the kingdom of God was
real to us right now not only that that
this kingdom was available to everyone
right now would it changed the way we do
things if we knew that God desired
reconciliation with our worst enemy the
God wanted us to drop our confusion over
religion and asked for our assistance in
showing the world how much God loves the
world I wonder how we might spice up the
bland soup of options that is offered to
us today from kwasi free market
capitalism to Kwazii socialism to
psychology that explains away our
behavior in organic terms to purely
therapeutic psychology that asks us to
bathe in our own feelings are the ways
we can explain to people why they are
the salt of the earth I watched 15 or so
of our students this past weekend many
from our church who were in a
homelessness immersion trip to New York
that we did the Calista and I were at
many of our deacons and others they were
cooking dinner and then sitting down and
eating with homeless strangers from the
streets of New York they were learning
about the stigmas and illusions about
homelessness and why people are homeless
they were handing out bags of food at
pantries and serving meals at soup
kitchens as I was writing back with the
group on the train last night I thought
about my own evaluation of the trip
would it solve the problem of
homelessness that we went no
what are to turn our students into
social workers and activists possibly
but probably not I think some will still
be chemists in the end but could it have
changed their minds their experience
their whole mental picture of who
homeless people are and what they're
worth as human beings I think it could I
think part of our job is not to fix the
world but to change the tone to change
the way the conversation happens to
interrupt people's patterns to interrupt
people's fears to interrupt the idea
that God loves the winners and hates the
losers that God has such strict
standards of goodness and seriousness
that God is always watching over us
waiting for us to screw up Christians
are sent out to the world to mess with
this message how might it work in
practice sometimes I think there's a
little bit of that old message at Yale
we see it when there's the presumption
that there's one right and serious and
excellent way to do everything there's
only one way and it's the perfect way
the exam must be written just so the
napkins must be folded just so and don't
ask me to define what just so is because
you should already know and if you dont
know dem are it's already a disaster i
wonder if we could be solved first to
this place and then to the world to say
is there way to turn down the heat and
turn up the laughter to trust to
cooperate to say what we mean and to
rather than being the salt in the desert
to be the salt in the bland soup
the unheard voice the human focus the
God focused view the Jesus view of the
world that you you you are the salt you
are the light you are God's blessing to
the world